well that's one of the most frightening  aspects of your book  okay you know we can get to that part  later a distinction that's important for  the audience it was important and  enlightening for me was between  vissen and kennen i believe they're  german words about knowledge yes do you  mind expanding  yes  or if you prefer  and connect in french and the simple way  of saying it is that  is knowing that  something is the case whereas connector  cannon is knowing something direct  so i know  that paris is the capital of france i  know paris because of the times i've  spent there and what they've meant to me  you know i know that um  you know the the the tree in my garden  is of a certain species and a certain um  height and  so forth but i only know it because i  walk past it stop under it and  experience it so really there's a  distinction between a kind of abstracted  form of knowing  data knowing things  about things  and the knowing of them rather than  about them